nichts ist lästiger als ein leerer akku
und so tüfteln forschungsteams weltweit
an innovativen ideen um uns das nervige
problem endlich für immer abzunehmen und
jetzt ist es wohl tatsächlich soweit ein
forschungsteam des samsung ex1 institute
of technology hat die grundlage für
einen neuartigen akku entwickelt der in
phänomenal kurzen zwölf minuten voll
geladen werden kann das geheimnis dieses
technischen traums graffy wie genau
dieser akku funktioniert und ob er
tatsächlich schon bald die
althergebrachten lithium ionen batterien
ersetzen wird jetzt in klicks und
science fiction herzlich willkommen wird
unser traum von einer langen
akkulaufzeit kombiniert mit einer kurzen
ladezeit jetzt schon bald tatsächlich
realität wenn man samsung glauben mag
dann ja die neu entwickelten batterien
des unternehmens laden in der theorie
nach eigenen angaben wohl bis zu fünfmal
schneller als die herkömmlichen
lithium-ionen-akkus
als basis dafür dient graf in dieser
stoff gilt schon länger als
allzweckwaffe technische träume aller
art wort zu machen im detail besteht es
aus einer einzigen transparenten schicht
aus kohlenstoffatom diese sind ähnlich
angeordnet wie bienenwaben dadurch
verein trafen mehrere wirklich krasse
eigenschaften
es ist das wohl dünnste material der
welt bis zu 300 mal fester als stahl
härter als diamant dabei aber flexibel
und leitfähiger als kupfer wahnsinn vor
13 jahren hat ein forschungsteam aus
manchester erstmalig eine anatomische
lage graphen hergestellt für ihre arbeit
bekamen die beiden wissenschaftler 2010
dem nobelpreis für physik und so hatte
man graphen aufgrund seiner zahlreichen
superlativ eigenschaften schon länger
als geeigneten kandidaten für die
herstellung von batterien auf dem schirm
doch es nutzbar für praktische
technologien zu machen das war bisher
nicht gelungen
der knackpunkt seine herstellung in
großen mengen und das zu einem
vernünftigen preis doch das ist jetzt
offensichtlich gelungen die samsung
forschungsgruppe aus südkorea hat das
material nach eigenen angaben aus einem
günstigen material nämlich
siliziumdioxid synthetisiert dazu der
beteiligte projektleiter sonne in lluc
und ist es gelungen
und werkstoff mit graphen in großen
mengen zu einem erschwinglichen preis
herzustellen bei der produktion erinnern
die vielen kleinen graffin bälle ein
wenig an popcorn die werden dann in
lithium ionen akku sowohl an der kathode
als auch an der anode verwendet und
erhöhen deren ladegeschwindigkeit um das
im detail zu verstehen
bei uns ein bisschen chemie die
kohlenstoffatome in grafing sitzen
jeweils auf den ecken von regelmäßig
angeordneten sechsecken die atome
wechselwirken ihre elektrischen felder
überlagert sich das verhalten der
elektronen führt dann dazu dass strom
1,5 mal besser geleitet wird als es bei
kupfer der fall ist denn die
kohlenstoffatome in graphen sorgen dafür
dass sich die ladungsträger quasi masse
los für die versprechen aus südkorea
sind kaum zu glauben an graf in accum
könne demnach in nur zwölf minuten voll
geladen werden zudem sei auch seine
kapazität im vergleich zu den
herkömmlichen lithium-ionen-akkus größer
und zwar um knapp die hälfte also
genauer um 45 prozent
diese höhere energiedichte führt also
letztendlich dazu dass mehr energie auf
kleinem raum gespeichert werden kann
doch die samsung forschungsgruppe
relativiert ihr ergebnis gleich wieder
ein wenig bis die neuen akkus in
industriellem stil hergestellt werden
können werden wohl noch einige jahre
vergehen
dennoch ist das jetzt ein riesenschritt
in der akkutechnologie denen sich wohl
auch viele andere industriezweige
nutzbar machen werden zum beispiel
könnten grafen bälle bei der
konstruktion von elektroautos helfen da
sie extrem temperatur stabil sind
samsung wittert hier zu recht ein
riesiges geschäft das unternehmen hat
bereits patente in südkorea und den usa
für seine herstellung der kaffee in
belle angemeldet wenn ihr kein video zu
diesem thema und auch zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht dem genau auf die sache nur dann
werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos
informiert wie geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken revolution super akkus
erfunden ja eine andere sensationelle
entwicklung in der akkutechnologie
ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleib dran